isabelle morini bosc oui voulais
demander pardon à quelqu'un ce soir
c'est assez étonnant
franchement je m'attendais pas du tout à
ça ben oui mais je voudrais demander
pardon à gilles giguère des gilles
verdez octobre il était ici à côté de
moi
malgré nos moments de complicité
m'exaspérait mais vraiment souvent parce
que je trouvais excessive parce qu'il
hurlait pas ce qui m'a rendu à moitié
sourde à moitié des 1 complètement
dingue est donc vraiment un moment je me
suis dit mais j'en ai marre quoi mais
qui ce tir eh ben depuis qu'il est parti
il me manque vraiment et il me manque
vraiment de plus en plus et ne
reviennent tous les moments de grandes
complicités et d'ailleurs j'en profite
gilles tu m'avais promis continuera
ensemble l'a pas encore fait il serait
temps que ça se fasse alors on vous a
préparé un petit lait me reviennent
beaucoup vous étiez un peu comme chiens
et chats
gillet vous et j'ai une petite surprise
pour vous après interdit hier c'était
nul dit le
[Applaudissements]
et bien déjà
gilles est venue ce soir
[Applaudissements]
ça fait plaisir quand je veux faire
chialer pour chialer et c'est vrai nous
avons kg il a oui mais parce que c'est
un amour de mec n'est pas tout ce que je
pense mais je pense tout ce que je dis
m'a vraiment manqué gilles vous manque
isabelle hains beaucoup alors vers tous
les soirs mais gilles on va pas se
mentir ici on dit toute la vérité
c'est vrai que vous êtes moins présent
on savait contrer vous allez très vite
revenir nous voir et on sait que des
dates et les saccades la télé donc il
est peu présent cette année
il est chez benjamin puis le vendredi
et bien sûr vous avez innové en revenir
nous voir les deux semaines c'est juste
voilà je vous le diront des civils at on
un peu c'est vrai que gilles il était là
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps mon gilet ce qu'on
vous manque alors oui je vous regarde
tout le temps vous manque et beaucoup
mais si je puis vous dire honnêtement
c'est beaucoup mieux sambre franchement
c'est pas vrai il ya beaucoup de gens
sur les réseaux sociaux qui disent que
vous voulez en moquez vous avez un truc
à dire isabelle ce soir mais je laime je
n'aime vraiment je me suis jeté sur elle
mais je laime kouame amoncelés toujours
dit si jamais on n'avait pas eu des vies
elles sont là on moi vous savez ouais là
oui on en rit oui mais oui on regarde et
on se touche on s'aime on est tactile en
est on est intellectuellement proches
pire actuellement tout ton physiquement
tout autrement qu allez-vous commerce
est bon
j'avais isabelle vous auriez pu vous
auriez pu avoir une aventure et jean oui
tout à fait je pense que vous êtes un
peu amoureuse de lui je crois mais voilà
moins à mitis et voilà c'est la
frontière kouame moore arrête dès qu'on
parle ni de politique ni d'histoires
normes et même je vais être un petit peu
amoureuse de lui
vous êtes autant en me montrant beaucoup
c'est vrai non mais attendez on est
amoureux par amitié et voilà les moyens
la plainte pénale est amoureuse de moi
me amicalement sa vraie vie mais oui
bien sûr mais il était mon frère mais
voilà tout le monde jean-michel sur
voila mais et et vous me suis sûr vous
allez finir ensemble
faites vos petits bisous ce week-end si
mais l'autre on va passer une partie
dure comment ça va se terminer sa
jeunesse avant ça à partir en cacahuète
flambée ça